aber eine breaking news die gerade
hereingekommen ist jetzt also doch alle
eltern müssen offenbar wieder zittern
bildungsministerin bettina stark
watzinger spricht corinna klartext und
ruft dazu auf sich zum schutz vor einer
möglichen infektionswelle durch omikron
auf neue schulschließungen vorzubereiten
in dieser situation müsse man
vorkehrungen auch für den
bildungsbereich treffen falls omikron
schlimm werte das ist das wörtliche
zitat das die fdp politikerin in einem
interview der funke mediengruppe
geäußert hat bei uns im studio wie der
bild chefreporter peter tiede für eine
einordnung ja also das was die
bildungsministerin darum die
bundesbildungsministerin da gesagt hat
könnte man unter normalen umständen
abtun als binsenweisheit wenn es nicht
mehr anders geht dann müssen wir die
schulen schließen sie beschreibt im
prinzip das was momentan in den
bundesländern abläuft weil nämlich auch
auf empfehlung des expertenrats der
bundesregierung dieses 19 köpfige
gremium hat am sonntag empfohlen sich
darauf einzustellen die kritische
infrastruktur zu schützen falls omikron
einschlägt was damit gemeint dass
nämlich viele arbeitgeber viele
arbeitnehmer gleichzeitig in quarantäne
müssen nicht mal im krankenhaus liegen
oder schwer erkrankt sind aber einfach
einen positiven test haben dadurch dass
auch mikron halt wirklich viel stärker
ansteckend da ist und die verdopplung
rate die sogenannte also die
verdoppelung der infektionszahlen stadt
in zehn bis 14 tagen die bisher in der
spitze abläuft dann in zwei bis drei
tagen das heißt also alles was ich über
diesen zeitraum sonst irgendwie
infizieren würde stapelt sich hochkommt
einen ganz kurzen zeitraum das würde
heißen ganz viele leute gleichzeitig in
quarantäne nicht zur arbeit betroffen
natürlich auch lehrer worauf müssen sich
dann einstellen kein lehrer das wechsel
unterricht das ist das was damit gemeint
ist also die ganzen krisenpläne die in
den schubladen liegen seit einem jahr
oder sagen wir mal liegen sollten die
werden in den bundesländern jetzt nach
und nach aktiviert das gilt zum beispiel
auch bei der polizei das gilt für
kurorten bildung bei der polizei oder
bei rettungsdiensten dass man sagt die
bilden gruppen von 10 15 leuten die in
festen schichten zusammenarbeiten die
nicht mehr genutzt werden mit anderen
dass wenn wir einen eintrag haben wenn
wir infektionen haben nicht alle krank
sind sondern nur eine gruppe aus dem
verkehr gezogen werden muss andere
können dann nur wieder anspringen aber
liegen solche notfallpläne an den
schulen nach zwei jahren pandemie nicht
schon längst von euch muss sagen ich
wunder mich extrem wenn es dann heißt ja
wir müssen die digitale ausstattung der
schulen rasch verbessern einsatz in die
bildungsministerin jetzt gesagt habe ich
denke im moment mal den hätten wir ja
vor zwei jahren oder spätestens vor
einem jahr verbessern müssen also
offenbar ist nicht viel passiert in den
schulen offenbar gibt es diese pläne
nicht als dass sie eine solche krise
auch wirklich halten können und wer dann
doch wieder an den punkt kommen wo die
kinder die leidtragenden sind und die
kinder nach hause also die notfallpläne
die existieren die gibt es die müssen
dahin nicht oder nein aber was nicht
funktioniert ist der sogenannte korona
alltag also dass in den schulen wirklich
flächendeckend bundesweit gleich
vorgesorgt war und ist also zum beispiel
nehmen wir mal die lüfter sollte neben
klassenraum soll eigentlich ein lüfter
stehen oder ein lüftungskonzept da sein
was ist dann warten bundesweit
flächendeckend eingekauft worden lüfter
die für wohnzimmer reichen aber nicht
für große klassenräume solche sachen da
da hapert ist hier muss man sagen es
gibt die notfallpläne die sind in den
schubladen die sind in allen 16
bundesländern jetzt nach und nach werden
deaktiviert zum beispiel jemand gehen
wir mal von der schule weg kommen wir
mal zur polizei weil da kann man schön
erklären in nordrhein westfalen hat
jetzt gespräche geführt schon
personalrat zur aktivierung der stufe 1
des katastrophen plans und da wird zum
beispiel ein kaskaden system erstellt
also wenn von oben nach unten wenn wenn
der kranke ist wer springt ein und das
geht dann durch und durch und durch also
wer ist da wenn wenn da drei weg sind
das wird überall gemacht und das wird
auch an den schulen gemacht aber von der
polizei habe ich nicht ob wir müssen
eventuell die polizei dicht machen von
denen ist aber ja weil die zahl der
lehrer ist dann halt begrenzt und dann
und sie sagt nicht wir wollen den
schulen schließen sondern sie sagt wir
müssen uns auf den fall vorbereiten und
das nicht genügend lehrer da sind dass
wir in den wechsel unterricht reingehen
müssen das ist ehrlich gesagt das was
ich ganz normal erwarte dass man in
einer krise dieser zwei jahren da ist
auf den fall vorbereitet ist das von
dass von 100 lehrer nur noch nur noch 20
da sind daher gehe ich davon aus dass
muss ich eigentlich davon ausgehen dass
meine schule dass mein
bildungsministerium dass mein landrat
und mein bürgermeister darauf
vorbereitet sind dass das kommt das ist
die bundesbildungsministerin die ja
eigentlich die
bundesforschungsministerin ist die für
bildung gar nicht so viel zuständig ist
schon gar nicht für die schulen das
jetzt sagt ist eigentlich eine binse
aber dass ihr sagen muss zeigt dass wir
nach wie vor nach zwei jahren immer noch
nicht so weit sind wie weit die sein
sollten das selbstverständlichkeiten
funktionieren und dass wir mit
sicherheit sagen können meine schule auf
die mein kind geht ist so vorbereitet
dass zur not schnell in wechsel
unterricht gegangen werden kann das ich
als elternteil rechtzeitig erfahren dein
kind kann morgen nicht in die schule
aber so und so muss das jetzt gelöst
werden oder aber wir machen einen rot
betrieb oder ein betreuungs bild betrieb
das ist flächendeckend in deutschland
nicht gegeben und deswegen schreckt
diese meldung jetzt auch wieder auf
während wir arbeitsunterlagen schon
jetzt mit nach hause bekommen nur zur
sicherheit mein sohn 21
ist ein wichtiger einordnungen also
keine willkürlichen maßnahmen sondern
eine vorbereitung auf den pfeil und im
zusammenhang mit dem möglichen
überlastung der krisen infrastruktur
vielen dank dafür